Russia's president of Vladimir Putin
says the move by Wagner forces is
treason and said decisive action will be
taken
we will defend our country we will
defend our nation we will defend our
citizens against the threats we face
today some people are trying to use
their interests against our country we
need to make sure that we are fighting
in Ukraine for the sake of our country
and be sure the Traders must not be
there a lot of people have sacrificed
their lives for Russia and those that
are trying to sow rebellion and create
chaos will fail ultimately
says Russia's president is mistaken and
Wagner Fighters are patriots not traces
the planes that leave for combat work in
Russia is offensive against Ukraine are
leaving as normal there aren't any
problems medical aircraft are leaving
there are no problems all they did was
take the aerodrome under control so that
the attack Aviation did not strike us
but strike ukrainians
the main commanding Center for Russia's
offensive in Ukraine is functioning as
normal there aren't any problems at all
not one officer has been pried away from
their work so when the Russian army tell
you that the private military company
Wagner has abstracted the work of the
army which resulted in things crumbling
on the front things will not crumble on
the front because of this when we came
here to roster on Dawn we reconfirmed a
lot of new things a huge amount of
territories have been lost soldiers have
been killed three four times more than
what it says in documents shown to the
top leadership
okay we're going to cross to Moscow to
speak with Union Chapel valova who's
there for us Julia you're joining us on
the phone let's talk more about evgeny
pragosan's reaction to these accusations
by President Putin what's he been saying
yeah yeah sure well basically to the
nation earlier on Mr Putin Russia's
fighting Goods future and its identity
and that authorities in Russia will not
allow the country to be divided they
will protect its people and He also
mentioned the conflict with Ukraine
saying that the entire Western military
machine was directed against Russia so
Putin indeed called the situation the
country treason uh saying that any
internal unrest is a deadly threat to
the state and to the people and the
pregosian has now reacted to Putin's
words about treason saying that
president was deeply wrong that they are
patriots meaning well himself and his
dog the fighters are calling them
patriots of their country and he said
that they would continue fighting for
their country uh they would continue
fighting uh corruption lie and
bureaucracy in the country so basically
we're getting some official reactions
here too well from the foreign Ministry
spokeswoman for for example she said
that Unity within the country is needed
and probably the same words that we
heard from the former president the
former president Dmitry Medvedev uh also
it looks like a new form of expression
of loyalty to Vladimir Putin and the
Russian Armed Forces uh on the telegram
and uh channels and other networks
officials in in their accounts uh right
that well they pose band name region and
organization saying that we are with the
president
so basically we also have some some
reports some telegram channels uh
associated with the Wagner group claimed
that there were clashes with the
ministry of Defense in the veronis
region and Military correspondence there
right about the work of Aviation along
the M4 highway but we can't immediately
verify those reports uh also they
investigative committee the Russian
investigative committee has launched a
criminal case against pregosian and the
FSB uh appealed to the fighters of the
Wagner group and urged them to obtain
pregosian and earlier on the head of
Gardner called on his supporters to join
the ranks of his military company and
sort had the so-called chaos and the
country saying uh that was not a
military coup that was a March of
Justice
really I'm just looking at some of the
agency pictures that we're getting from
the center of Moscow at the moment and
it does actually seem to be fairly uh
quiet there but I do know that security
has been stepped up across Russia what
have you been hearing
well that's absolutely right some
armored military personnel carers and
other armored vehicles that could be
seen in the streets of Moscow but
generally you're right people say that
the capital looks pretty calm at the
moment but security measures have been
tightened in Moscow and not just Moscow
and other uh regions of Russia too and
uh here all the most important
facilities have been taken under
protection uh they're also reports that
all the public activities have been
canceled and things like problems at
schools and other venues have been
postponed uh by the way I just forgot to
mention the ministry of Defense earlier
on also issued an official statement
addressing fighters of this organic
group saying that they had got involved
in pregosians criminal activities and
participated in an in an armed rebellion
and uh well they they shouldn't actually
they they also guaranteed everyone's
safety it devices surrendered and as we
see there are reports by state media
Outlets saying that some Fighters
returns to their initial position as
they have been asked by the Army
um well also some publications of
preggers well basically some sources uh
that published the pregocian's earlier
statements and uh well actually and
after we've seen his actions since that
we haven't seen a lot of clashes between
Wagner and the regular army basically
there are reports that the Wagner group
Now controls the command center and the
number of security and Military facility
that his facilities in Russia's southern
city of rostov including an Airfield but
according to reports the military planes
there continue carrying out their
mission uh also According to some
Security Services uh well the situation
of uncertainty is is going on in
varonish because some say that some
command centers have also been captured
by Wagner there but those reports hadn't
been officially confirmed
um also there have been pictures showing
pregocia negotiating with two
high-ranking Army generals uh you know
that you've curab and general Alexis and
they were warning progosian about uh
consequences of his actions uh so
basically pregosian claimed that the
Wagner forces had shot down a health had
shot down a helicopter that opened fire
on a civilian Convoy while other sources
report about two army helicopters firing
at several Wagner vehicles in the rostov
region but that information has been
officially confirmed either so we do
keep monitoring the developments here in
Moscow
Yulia thank you very much indeed that's
Julius talking to us from Moscow and the
phone will joining us now from
donetsky's Ali Hashem now euron donetsky
across the border from orastavon Don
where much of the activity is taking
place it is difficult at the moment as
we know to get information out from
nostal vondon to find out what's going
on as far as you're aware what's been
happening
well since this morning uh the whole
operation by Wagner was centralized in
resolved the Wagner troops went into the
City without any resistance to control
of the command center there and as we
saw and we had also from Yulia the
commander of the Wagner group Evgeni
pregosian made a video
or an audio response to the president
over the speech he stayed away from
using harsh words towards the president
by for example saying that he is not
saying the truth however I didn't really
go directly to attack the president and
it's it's clear that he wants to keep
kind of an association with the country
or the establishment away from his food
with the uh with the with the government
or with the military commanders now in
in rostov for now what we know is that
the Wagner are in control also on the
way to varanej they have also some
activities there they posted a video of
a photo of a helicopter that was hit
however this needs to be confirmed also
other areas such as liptisk this is
another city to the north of of rustov
that the Wagner troops also claim to
have control of without any resistance
now since yesterday Wagner's commander
of guinea pig origin said that he is
going to head towards roster because the
defense minister launched his the what
what Wagner's Commander claim is an
attack on his troops from rostov and
that he's going there for a for a kind
of a Revenge now how is this impacting
the situation over here in Donetsk there
is nothing in the city however we've
been hearing for the past hours
bombardment around the city the defense
Ministry also claimed that the
ukrainians the Korean forces are
preparing for a counter offenses or
offensive in Bahamut and this is also
part of the repercussions of what's
happening so the president the Russian
president is right now in front of
really dangerous Crossroads either
engaging with uh Wagner troops
militarily and this could pose a threat
on the Civil order I might ignite the
Civil War in the country or accept
whatever is uh Wagner is is requesting
and this will undermine the military
establishment of the country and the
time of what Russia calls a special
operation or and the weight of a of a
war in Ukraine yeah Alan you were saying
there that um
Evgeni pragosan had been staying away
from criticizing President Putin he has
in his most recent statement said that
nobody plans to turn themselves in on
Putin's order which does bring the two
of them a bit closer we're going to be
coming back to you of course in the next
couple of hours to find out what the
latest developments but for now Ali
Hashem thank you very much
well there's been no pause in Russia's
offensive in Ukraine we're going to
cross live to Jonah Hall in Keith how is
all of this being viewed in key first of
all
well obviously they'll be watching it
extremely closely not just the political
leadership here in key but the military
leadership uh as well we've had some
comments from president zielinski uh
who's taken to telegram with a rather
long uh post decrying overnight missile
attacks on targets all over Ukraine once
again saying that it is all Happening by
the will of one man and saying that
Russia's weakness is now obvious uh as
long as Russia keeps its troops and
mercenaries on our land he says the more
chaos pain and problems will come to it
later more specifically though comments
from Michaela podoliak an advisor to
president zielinski and we've heard lots
of people suggesting that whatever does
happen next in Russia could well happen
very swiftly that appears to be the view
as well among the political leadership
here Michael podoliak talking about the
next 48 hours and saying they will
determine what he described as the new
status in Russia either a fully fledged
Civil War or a contractual transition of
power or a temporary respite before the
next stage of the fall of the Putin
regime of course they will not have any
better idea than anyone else about what
is going to happen next militarily
though it could have much uh Stronger
bearings and ramifications on the
process of the war itself and the
military analysts here will be watching
very closely all of their sources their
satellite imagery and so on to see what
they can glean about what's happening in
roster Bond on it is absolutely vital
military center for the war here it is
the base of the Southern military
District which is operating and
controlling almost all of the
battlefield here in Ukraine they'll be
looking at ways in which that may be
disrupted they'll be looking at
infrastructure that may be disrupted
roots of resupply and reinforcement for
the forces in the Security operation
that is going on there and they'll be
looking specifically as well at points
on the very long front line here in
Ukraine with a view to the cam offensive
offensive that's been going on for
several weeks now probing Russia's
defenses at a number of points they're
one to know or try to understand just
how many of those Wagner mercenaries
have been redeployed from positions that
they have been holding and defending
along the battlefield
two Mainland Russia thinking of places
like bakmut big city in the East that
was fought over specifically by Wagner
mercenaries they'll be looking to see
whether little holes are exposed there
for them to exploit and they'll also of
course be looking to see the composition
of Russian forces along the front lines
here perhaps not the first line of
defense but rear echelons is Russia
needing to redeploy some of its key
assets on the ground in Ukraine to
support its attempt to see off Wagner
mercenaries in Russia itself Jonah just
as you're talking to us we can see
behind you the the workmen there who are
beginning to clear up the debris there
have been airstrikes haven't there over
the last few hours or so tell us about
those
yeah it's a pretty extraordinary scene
here you know a reminder as if any were
needed that there is very much a war
still going on and it is going on away
from the front lines in the South and
the East Kiev hit overnight uh by a
barrage of missiles some 20 cruise
missiles fired at the Capitol uh for the
eighth time this month alone air
defenses were able to bring all of them
down we are told by the city military
Administration but that creates debris
in the air and that debris got to fall
somewhere and it appears that a large
piece of missile debris potentially
containing payload unexploded hit this
high-rise apartment building scithing an
enormous hole in three sides of it
igniting a fire across three stories
three people known to have died rescue
workers believe there could be further
victims and here where I'm standing a
big clear-up operation underway an
enormous debris field here falling
masonry furniture trip from those
apartments and so on and an awful lot of
people coming here to take a look
Jonah thank you very much Jonah Hall in
Keith we're going to get a view from the
front lines about these dramatic
developments we've been talking about
Charles Stratford is joining us on the
road to Bach mote in eastern Ukraine
you've been in a village on the front
line with some of the fighters that talk
us through what you and the team have
been seeing not just there of course but
obviously in the last couple of hours uh
since all this stuff has been happening
in roster vondon
that's right yeah you join us on the
road to bakmut of course that town that
was taking control of by Russian forces
in relative recent weeks and a town that
was taking control of with the
fundamental role of the Wagner group we
know that certainly according to
Ukrainian forces they're saying that
since this counter-offensive has started
they're claiming to have made certain
gains in trying to retake control of
Bahamut from the south south east and
south west pushing North but of course
this news that we're hearing now has
potentially huge impact on this
counter-offensive and interestingly
we've been speaking to Ukrainian
soldiers in this area are they
describing it as a big day for Ukraine
one soldier saying that they were now
going to in his words exploit the chaos
on the Russian side or the Russian
control side of the front line around
bakmut and hit Russian forces hard in
that area and we're already hearing
reports certainly on telegram that we
cannot independently verify of small
gains being made in the last few hours
or so but as I say we cannot
independently verify that what we can
tell you though is that we have seen
increased troop movement in this area
this morning we saw helicopters that are
designed to carry troops to the front in
this area there's been a lot of heavy
shelling as well both incoming and
outgoing smoke rising to my right off
camera
so yeah the situation is very tense here
but the morale amongst the Ukrainian
forces seems to have been buoyed by this
news now we've been looking at two
separate points along this thousand
kilometer front line to try and gauge
the difficulties that Ukrainian forces
are facing in the early stages of this
counter-offensive and this is our report
Russian forces have withdrawn from what
remains of this part of the village
people have fled
a destroyed Ukrainian military vehicle
is towed from the battlefield
dead Russian soldiers in the grass
the Ukrainian military last week
announced it had completely retaken The
Village
but that's not quite true
the crater you can see here is as a
result of a Russian airstrike
yesterday the Ukrainian military are
telling us that
although they've cleared so they say the
majority of this Village there is still
ongoing fighting on the outskirts
and they say they are facing Fierce
resistance from Russian forces
Ukraine's counter-offensive was expected
for months and that gave Russian forces
time to prepare
they have strong air power and a lot of
infantry supported by Heavy Artillery
they're moving slowly towards us but
we're killing them we're conducting
small offensive operations on the
outskirts of the village along the
Forest Lane but there are many mines
around 200 kilometers North near the
Russian occupied town of cremina barrage
after barrage of artillery fire Echoes
through the forests
Ukrainian soldiers here are nervous
Russian positions are a few hundred
meters away
Ukrainian forces retook this area during
a counter-offensive last summer neither
side has made a major advance for months
but as the Ukrainian Army began to probe
for weakness in Russian defenses to the
south things here began to change
honestly there is nothing good here the
situation is very tense
the trench Commander tells us to take
cover because Russian helicopter
gunships are in the area
there is constant fire from mortars
artillery helicopters airstrikes and
Small Arms they assault our position in
small groups they are trying to break
through to capture an important Supply
route
hard graft and early days says Ukraine
and its NATO backers
if there ever is a decisive breakthrough
it could take months Charles traffic Al
Jazeera eastern Ukraine